قبل أكثر من ثلاثة أشهر بقليل ،
أنهى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني جميع القيود القانونية المتعلقة بالوباء
التي كانت سارية منذ
أكثر من عام ، وفي حين أن القواعد
قد تلاشت ، إلا أن فيروس كورونا بقي في
الواقع ، تظهر الأرقام الأخيرة من المملكة المتحدة
أعلى معدل إصابة في أوروبا.
الآن ما يقرب من 50000 حالة جديدة تم
الإبلاغ عنها يوم الاثنين وهو أعلى مستوى منذ
يوليو / تموز ، دكتور إيريك توبول هو طبيب قلب
وأستاذ الطب الجزيئي في
أبحاث سكريبس ، انضم إلينا الآن من لا
جولا في كاليفورنيا ، أهلا وسهلا بك مرة أخرى
لرؤيتك
جيدة لتكون معك جون شكرا حسنا
في الوقت الذي تم فيه رفع القيود
في المملكة المتحدة ، كان من المتوقع
أن يرتفع معدل الإصابة بعد فترة وجيزة جدًا ،
لكنك تعلم أن طرح لقاح ناجح
قد حصل على الفضل لأنك تعلم
أن منع حدوث ذلك على
الفور ولكن الآن تلك اللقاحات
التي بدأت في ديسمبر من العام الماضي  هذا
يعني أن الملايين
قد تم تطعيمهم منذ أكثر من ستة
أشهر ، فهل هناك ما يشير هنا إلى أن
المناعة المتضائلة هي البلايلين  ga دور مهم إلى حد ما
في هذه الطفرة الحالية
، لقد ذكرت أن أحد
العوامل بالطبع هو الافتقار إلى التخفيف الحقيقي ،
لكن أضف إلى ذلك الآن
المشكلة الآخذة في التضاؤل ، فالدول التي حصلت عل
بداية مبكرة مثل المملكة المتحدة وإسرائيل ، وا
ولايات المتحدة لديها  الأكثر تضاؤلًا لذلك
هذا جزء منه أيضًا
قصة تلقيح المراهقين أه
الذي أه إن المملكة المتحدة منخفضة
مقارنة بالدول الأخرى في أوروبا
أه وهكذا تعلمون الشيء
الآخر بالطبع الذي يجب ملاحظته لا يزال في السادسة والستين
النسبة المئوية لسكان المملكة المتحدة
الذين تم تطعيمهم في البلدان الأكثر
نجاحًا حول العالم
هم 80 بالمائة على الأقل ، لذلك هناك العديد من
الأسباب المختلفة التي يمكن أن تساهم
في المشكلات التي نراها في المملكة المتحدة
ومن المحتمل أن يتم
تكرارها في  بلدان اخرى